these photos show some of Kim jong-un's
most iconic public appearances as North
Korea's leader over the past 12
years from 2011 when he came to power
following his father's death to one of
the many events he attended as North
Korea emerged from the coronavirus
pandemic Jenny town is the director of
38 North a North Korea focused website
she has been studying the subtle shifts
in Kim's attire over the years Kim
dongan is the the face of North Korea
and the Persona that he puts out um
really tells you how he wants the people
to see him we look at what can be
gleaned about The Changing State of
North Korea from Kim's wardrobe
choices and what his different looks
signal about the future of his
regime Kim Jong own's public appearances
are all carefully choreographed and
often packed with symbolism in late 2019
Kim was pictured riding on a white horse
through Mount piku the mountain is one
of the country's most sacred sites a
place many North Koreans believe to be
where the first Korean kingdom was
founded these were special horses that
were gifted to the Kim family only the
leaders have these special horses they
would only have a photo shoot here if it
was a very important message they were
trying to send this was the North
Koreans were going to do it in their own
way reasserting that self-reliance
attitude
descendants of the Kim family namely Kim
jong-un's late grandfather Kim ILS and
father Kim Jong Il seen standing on the
mounting in this painting have run the
country since its founding more than 70
years ago in another painting of the two
former North Korean leaders on the peak
shows there's one outfit that's common
between all three Kims the ma
suit the pointed collar two the neck
buttoning and the four pockets in the
front the suit is now known as the Mal
suit in the west because they were
popularized during the reign of Mal zong
the founder of communist
China it's one of Kim's most common
wardrobe choices you can see here
especially at the beginning of Kim dun's
tenure as the leader you saw him wear
this quite
often Kim wore the male suit when he met
with Chinese leader Xi Jinping during
his first trip abroad since coming to
power in
2018 he also wore similar outfits in
talks with different world leaders at a
time when pongyang was negotiating
nuclear disarmament with the US my
friend he met with Donald Trump he had
this typical ma suit on that was very
representative of the North Korean
identity it might have been yeah to
differentiate himself from the other
world leaders and to maintain that North
Korean
presence but Kim also likes to wear
Western suits especially while attending
events back home t says this shows Kim
wants to portray a different image for
the domestic audience in one of his new
year's speeches he started to wear these
Western suits in these formal meetings
and especially the important ones there
wasn't the mous suit anymore
domestically you saw much more of this
Global Persona much more of this western
style look I think there was a level of
confidence here and a trying to portray
that the country was moving forward and
especially on equal terms with the rest
of the
world Kim's appearance before during and
after the covid-19 pandemic reflects his
political
messaging as negotiations over North
Korea's denuclearization collapsed in
2019 Kim made frequent public outings in
a bid to Rally the country he was out
doing site visits like this one here but
he's you know out with the people in a
pretty typical attire that's seasonally
approp apprpriate but casual to try and
you know connect with the people more
there was a lot of note that he was out
doing these site visits maybe about
every couple of
weeks but when covid-19 began to spread
across the globe and North Korea closed
its borders Kim barely appeared in
public towards the the middle to end of
the pandemic we did see sort of a new
Kim dun emerge you can see especially in
this picture how much um thinner he is
especially compared to this one here one
of the narratives that went on at that
time domestically was that the the
people were also so concerned that he
had lost so much weight and that he was
suffering for the people along with the
people um during a very difficult time
for the
country but as the pandemic came to an
end and North Korea began its gradual
reopening Kim started to look more like
his old self there was definitely a
shift in the public narrative in in Kim
dun's priorities as well um a real shift
towards more U military
development we saw a lot of new missile
systems being tested and
developed we saw a lot more military
activity when the economy wasn't doing
so good that does convey a sense of
[Music]
optimism in March 2022 North Korean
State media released a heavily edited
video showing Kim wearing sunglasses and
black leather jacket as he oversaw the
test of a new intercontinental ballistic
missile for him to have come out in this
bomber jacket really set the tone of
trying to create his own Persona trying
to look more Western maybe it was trying
to look kind of like Top
Gun the Top Gun style jacket marked to
shift away from the outfits that
symbolized the cult of personality
around his father and grandfather this
is a good kind of depiction of the
evolution of of kimjongun here we see
him with the much more traditional look
trying to look like his grandfather
trying to um emulate that kind of
traditional Persona and here he's he's
his own man right like he's he's had a
lot of successes especially in the
military front uh and the missile front
and things that his father and
grandfather hadn't been able to
accomplish and we have seen Kim Dungan
throughout this period as he develops
his own not only style but also his own
style of
leadership